hey everyone my name is John Roca I'm
from Collider I'm here with three of the
incredible cast members from Richard
Jewell please excuse my throat I was
coughing all night so but I'm ready that
because I couldn't turn down an
opportunity to view Sam Rockwell Kathy
Bates and Jon Hamm I want to start off
first by saying I wanna start my first
question Kathy you're always playing
these strong no-nonsense women and at
first glance you might not think Bobby
jewel is but she shows us a different
kind of strength you give her the
strength throughout the movie I don't
know what did you strive to bring to
your portrayal of her that you thought
was the most important thing for you
her resilience I would say and her deep
love of her son she's still hurting it's
still very emotional even after all
these what does he just say it was 23
years since it happened it's still very
emotional and even though I'm not a mom
I wanted to glean as much as I could
from her I know she had miscarriages and
he was her only son and so it was you
know and I just wanted to get it right
for her we all I think wanted justice
for Richard okay Sam you're no stranger
to playing these scenes dealing
quote/unquote supporting characters for
lack of better term from guy and Galaxy
Quest to Watson Brian and Richard Jewell
now but there was a freedom that you
gave Watson and I don't think I've seen
you play in any of your roles and I want
to know was there was that something you
brought to it yourself personally or was
it conversations with people around
Richard your lawyer and now like I met
with the real Watson yeah Brian and he's
he's pretty pretty colorful character
he's really interesting that to be
around he's he's very cocky and he's
funny and he's opinionated he's a lot of
things so it was he pretty easy -
there's a lot to draw from yeah
as an actor were you excited when you
met him you're like oh I can play this
yeah definitely definitely
he was boy he's wild yeah he's wild yeah
it comes through certainly John you are
back playing an FBI agent you know we're
a national organization Claire met from
the town it's not easy to play a villain
in these
and a piece like this what did you focus
on getting right with him in your scenes
well you know I think it's it's it's
it's hard it's hard to describe this guy
is the necessarily the villain um
because I don't think there's really any
malice and what he's doing is he's
trying to do his job and he's just he
does it to the best of his ability and
he's he survives on his instinct and his
in the strength of his conviction and
and and he just got it wrong yeah and it
happens sometimes and I think we have to
remember that sometimes that happens you
know I think when when you just take
everything at face value as the case was
here it can sometimes be wrong and all
the evidence can point in one direction
and it can point in the wrong direction
which was the case here and when they
end up finally catching the guy that did
it by that point he had bombed he had
set off four other bombs and planted
several others that hadn't exploded yet
and so that guy's in jail for the rest
of all of everybody's life so that's
that's the important thing to remember
is just that you know the movie isn't
really about an indictment of law
enforcement or media or anything it's
just that let's let's let's think and
before we rush to judgment on things
like that yeah and I think you know
what's great about this film is that
everyone gets to breathe such a part of
a life of these characters I I cried a
couple times throughout the movie just
the emotion of exact member living
through it and then seeing it again all
over again I think the weight and the
gravity and the talent you all brought
to these characters to bring them with
life for us again in a more visceral way
was fantastic when I was one last
question from the three of you obviously
actors talk you all working with Clint
Eastwood like what was the preparation
for all three you maybe separately or
together before you walk on a sabic
leanest food who's known to do one or
two takes and moving on yeah I was
pretty nervous when I did my first scene
with him but he's so gentle and kind and
he's he's an actor as well as a
wonderful director so he knows us and he
you know when I was working on a press
conference scene I was trying to you
know work on my emotion
and he noticed a few people coming over
and he said leave her alone leave her
alone
you know and I really appreciated that
you know because a lot of directors they
just sit behind the video no they and
you it's an adversarial role and he's
right in there with you very engaged you
know I was very engaged in all facets of
it it was really lovely to see that's
awesome but diapers I like it all right
this is John Rocker for Collider with
Sam Rockwell candy beets and Jon Hamm
for Richard Jewell go see this one trust
me you'll love it